there's been a multi-year story that
we've been following and it's the story
of brexit and the primary question has
been will brexit happen or will it not
is Britain going to leave the European
Union or are they going to end up
staying and as I said the day after the
vote June 23 2016 it may never happen
Breck's it may never happen and of
course we now know that if the vote were
to be held again today
remain would likely win although there
are questions of listen they did vote
this way back in 2016 for how long does
that vote remain considered the will of
the people there are all sorts of
questions like that but more recently
there have been much more pressing sort
of obstacles the former Prime Minister
Teresa may multiple times attempting to
finalize a deal to structure the leaving
of the European Union and failing and
ultimately the question was was will she
be able to outlast the criticism and the
calls for her to leave and ultimately
she left and Boris Johnson came in Boris
Johnson trumpian in many ways certainly
physically in his physical appearance
although that's not the most important
way the leader of the Conservative Party
now the prime minister will he finally
do brexit for the Nationalists and the
isolationists who want the UK out of the
EU or will he also fail and so far it's
really not working particularly well for
him he has between having one Tory MP
defect and kicking 20 others out for not
supporting him he very quickly seems not
to have the numbers that he needs to get
to the next step in the brexit process
so bottom line there has been one
defection a Tory MP who bailed on Boris
Johnson's party 20 other Tory MPs are
Tories or at least they were but they
didn't go along with what Boris Johnson
wanted and they were ejected and now all
of a sudden Boris Johnson finds himself
and yet another one of these
embarrassing scenarios for the Pro
brexit side giving the opposition
control of the agenda in
Parliament Johnson is soon going to have
to pay face those Prime Minister's
Questions for the first time which can
get very very crazy
the opposition of course is going to
continue to try to delay brexit and
Boris Johnson may call for a general
election a really a devastating defeat
for Johnson I know that you know the
standards and the the sort of rules of
decorum and how to interpret political
happenings in different countries can be
difficult when we're not familiarized
with the system and for what the sort of
Overton Window is for what we can expect
in terms of what is possible on one side
and the other side but this is an
embarrassing defeat for Johnson here's
video from yesterday in Parliament where
members of Johnson's own party abandon
him and vote to allow a debate to once
again postpone brexit and the question
becomes does it seem as though this is
ultimately turning into an indefinite
postponement total chaos breaking out
take a look at the first clip the eyes
to the right 328 the nose to the left
301
[Applause]
not a good start increase order the eyes
to the right 328 the nose to the left
301 to the eyes of it the eyes have it a
lot of course point of order the Prime
Minister Speaker I think
[Applause]
by the consequences of this vote tonight
it means that Parliament is on the brink
of wrecking any deal that we might be
able to sway
and control of the negotiations to the
EU and that would be more dinner more
delay and more confusion
[Applause]
you themselves would be able to decide
how long to keep this country in the ear
and since I refused to go along with
that plan we are going to have to make a
choice it is to speak I don't want an
election the public election but if the
housemates for this bill tomorrow the
public will have to choose who goes to
Brussels on October the 17th the sort
besides and take this country forward
what I love about the system is that
Trump definitely couldn't handle it and
I'm reminded of it because when you look
at Boris Johnson the look he looks very
trumpian like I said but he has a
slightly more wits about him expression
on his face than Trump can you imagine
Donald Trump ever having to handle
something like this I mean the guy just
literally could not he'd implode and to
under this kind of actual intense
scrutiny and this continuing to build as
eventually Boris Johnson suffering
abandonments and real chaos breaks out
Jeremy Corbyn ultimately speaking there
is no consent in this house to leave the
European Union without a deal there is
no majority for no deal in the country
as I've said before if the Prime
Minister has the confidence in his
brexit policy when he has one he can put
forward he should put it before the
people in a public vote
[Applause]
he wants the table emotion for a general
election fine get the bill through
[Applause]
in order
in order to take no deal off the table
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
very rude the members order order I
think the Chancellor of the Duchy that
when he turns up at our children's
school as a parent he's a very well
behaved fellow he wouldn't dare behave
like that in front of Colleen all and
neither would I danger stinky late
don't rant spare us the theatrics behave
yourself
[Applause]
things are really getting crazy and
what's even wackier is that this was all
merely a debate over what to order for
lunch no I'm kidding
but this I still believe in the end that
it is a likely scenario that the UK may
never leave the European Union if it
does it may not happen under Boris
Johnson the way his prime ministership
has been going in its very early days at
this point in time and we actually are
asking you what you think will
ultimately happen we've pulled our
audience every you know once a year or
so since this has gone down since the
vote went down in 2016 if you go to the
community tab on the david pakman show
youtube channel youtube.com slash the
david pakman show slash community do you
think the UK will ever actually brexit
we will have results either later this
week or maybe early next week